hey guys it is the 25th of March today
my name is jeff mcdonald and you'll
watching games but news myself that big
ps4 uptight we've been expecting is
coming tomorrow and with it a bunch of
new ps4 functionality new features
include the suspend resume function
which lets you enter and then exit rest
mode instantly you'll also be able to
backup your data to hard drives and USB
connect more easily with facebook
friends share the trophies that you've
earned on social media and upload video
clips to dailymotion should you want to
do that there are also verified accounts
for industry professionals and sub
accounts for under-18s can now be
upgraded to master accounts as if that
wasn't enough 60 frames per second
remote play and share play will also be
enabled the games that can run at the
lofty frame rate and there are a number
of new options that apply to the user
interface including expanded
accessibility options the update called
yukimura goes live tomorrow co-founder
of Apple Steve Wozniak has echoed the
thoughts of Bill Gates and Elon Musk by
saying we should be way more scared of
robots than we currently are speaking on
the subject of super-intelligent AI
Wozniak has said I agree that the future
is scary and very bad for people if we
build these devices to take care of
everything for us eventually they'll
think faster than us and they'll get rid
of the slow humans to run companies more
efficiently previously Stephen Hawking
called AI the worst thing for Humanity
so I guess all that programming work
going into making video game enemies for
you to fight could come back to haunt
you later in life hello is coming back
to pc but there's a catch well there's a
few cancers halo online is a
free-to-play multiplayer game whose beta
will be launching this spring and so
long as you live in Russia you can play
it halo online runs on a modded version
of the halo 3
is optimized for PCs and won't be coming
to Xbox one microsoft announced halo
online is set on a secret UNSC space
installation called anvil where's bars
and floor soldiers trained together in
war exercises to sharpen their battle
skills and test experimental technology
there's no campaign mode and it's
sounding unlikely this one will make its
weight in North America halo online is
being developed by saber interactive who
are responsible to the time shift and
inversion franchises they also worked on
halo combat evolved anniversary and halo
the master chief collection although
that last one might not be a game you
want on your resume if you're trying to
make a multiplayer only game let me know
down in the comments if this was the
halo game you wanted for PC or not and
why you can add to gamespot or we've got
stories on when the dragon age dlc will
be coming to ps4 and a brand new massive
explore image those are all the good
things that I wanted to tell you about
today do remember i'll be back same time
for with a bunch more news but have a
good one until then